[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and the broadcaster and former mp
anna subray so very good evening to both
of you
so let's take a look then at what's
making the front pages first of all with
uh still a few to come in but here's
what we've got so far the i reports that
on a record-setting day with more than a
hundred thousand new covered cases
new research emerged appearing to show
the risk of hospitalization from omicron
is lower than from previous variants
indeed the telegraph suggests that
omicron patients are two-thirds less
likely to end up in hospital which is
prompting some ministers to insist that
new restrictions aren't necessary
but the guardian puts that lower risk
figure at 40 percent while the male
cites a study claiming the number is 50
and the financial times carries warnings
from energy companies of stratospheric
wholesale price increases in the new
year which they say could lead to a
national crisis
so andrew pearce and anna subrie here to
go through those front pages with us are
still more to come in um of course but
the
the main theme of most of the headlines
we've got so far is this new
data that's come out this real world
data that we've got andrew you picked
out the i first of all omicron is lower
risk than delta cases that's the finding
but as the eye points out cases are
hitting new records
yeah look on about it normally uh the
fact that cases have gone above a
hundred thousand for the first time
would be a real it would be a real jolt
it would really worry people and depress
people but it's offset by this really
really encouraging news that's coming
out from uh research in scotland which
shows that the the omicron variant is
much less dangerous to the public health
than the delta variant so in fact
two-thirds less likely to be
hospitalized they've been analyzing the
figures uh admittedly there are no very
old people involved or people with
underlying health issues but normally
they would have expected at this stage
47 48 49 people to be in hospital it's
only 15. this is still very early stages
but there's also information coming out
of south africa where this wretched
variant began uh also suggesting that
hospitalizations are there are fewer of
them and that people are going to become
less sick which is really really
encouraging because by god don't we need
to be cheered up because um christmas
has been uncertain new year has been
uncertain
and this will cheer people no end we
mustn't jump too many conclusions but
it's a very good sign and it's pointing
in the right direction well yes so some
good news on the front page is um anna
subree but the other part of that i
headline
is still concerning isn't it um cases
hit new record and the fact is that we
also know that omicron is more
transmissible as well than other
variants and that that may wipe out the
gains if you like that we've got from
the lower risk of hospitalization
yes absolutely and you know we can't
take anything for granted um but this is
frankly the sort of news that we all
would welcome going up to christmas
because it is so grim
uh the figures are
obviously at a record high so i think
the caution i would put into it is not
losing sight of the fact that the
vaccine program the booster program has
as it will continue but i think it's
critical now that the government makes
every effort to get those people who
have not been vaccinated and there's
still a significant number of people i
mean in the city of nottingham it's
somewhere around 40 percent of people
who haven't had both jabs but there are
people of course who haven't even had
one so there's a big piece of work to do
there in addition obviously to keep on
ruling out the booster program and i
still think that we all have to be
cautious because what we mustn't take
our eye off is that
if you guess it
you are going to there's a good chance
you'll be bedridden and of course
because of the now seven-day requirement
to self-isolate that's having a huge
knock-on effect on businesses on public
services and of course the nhs putting
huge strains at a stressful time in
terms of people going into hospital and
getting poorly
on the staff there and its ability to
cope so i still think we've all got to
be sensible well yes and the daily
telegraph also picks up these studies as
you say pointed out andrew there are a
few of them they go with the headline
omicron hospital risk is two-thirds
lower but their subheading there says
ministers say tougher restrictions can't
be justified basically as a result of
these studies i mean we've heard from
the other nations we've heard from from
wales scotland and northern ireland
saying that after christmas there will
be some restrictions on behavior we've
not heard a verdict yet as far as
england is concerned do we have enough
information now do you think
well um look there was a cabinet meeting
which lasted three hours earlier this
week as we know and eight or nine
ministers spoke out against the idea of
any more additional restrictions because
in a sense um plan b has effectively
achieved a form of lockdown already by
stealth because chris whittie um the
chief medical officer spoke differently
to boris johnson at the briefing earlier
this week and if you look at most town
centres and city centres they're pretty
deserted high streets are pretty
deserted public transport is pretty thin
and empty so in a sense if
chris whitty got his way really because
we've gone into a form of lockdown
without actually saying we're going into
lockdown which is why a lot of ministers
and tory mps are saying that's enough
now because we've already
shut down large parts of the economy
it's why the chancellor's had to bring
forward money for the hospitality
industry because it's been so badly
affected at its most critical period in
the whole year
do you think that's right and uh i mean
we've heard from wales first minister
today when he introduced some new
measures uh for wales including bringing
about the rule of six from boxing day
for for example he's accused uh boris
johnson's government of being of
paralysis uh when making decisions uh
over england do you think that's fair
saying that yeah i do think it's fair
because
you know
and he gives advice now which i think
what's happened is because of this
breakdown of trust with our prime
minister because he's found out to
not be um how do we put it socially
distance from the truth is a feature of
his uh premiership and people have lost
trust and faith in boris johnson and so
they're gonna they're turning to people
that they do trust because unfortunately
the government does have a history of
always being
behind the curve acting too late and
that's why people themselves you know i
agree with andrew
people themselves have said well
actually i'm more inclined to believe
chris whittie and i'm just going to take
things nice and easy and you only have
to look at your own life i mean i i
don't live in london i've got two
daughters that do both of whom have got
covered it seems that half of london's
got coping i think these figures by the
way will also be well behind the actual
real figures uh relating to the number
of people who are infected um andrew i
noticed you were shaking your head when
anna was first answering that i i i
don't i don't agree with uh um mark
drakeford the welsh first minister about
the government being in paralysis i
think actually the prime minister has
just listened to his parliamentary party
and his ministers for a change he had
not been listening at all and i think is
quite good that that's happening but
also um i want to say about london the
reason we've got a real problem in
london which is the petri dish frankly
of the united kingdom for this this
variant is because so many people in
london are not vaccinated around 10
percent haven't had one vaccination let
alone a booster and anna super he talked
about how we've got to persuade these
people yeah but how because we've been
this booster program has been this jab
program's been running for months and
months and months they're stubbornly
refusing to do it now i'm not one of
those who thinks you've got to compel
them but you do despair sometimes that
we're never going to get
sorted with this variant if so many
people continue to refuse to have the
to have the jab because they believe all
this conspiracy rubbish on the internet
and very quickly let's just show the
guardian we agree on that okay sorry the
guardian's front page again with the new
data there's subhead there warnings that
nhs may still be overwhelmed as daily
cases hit 106 000 so a different tone to
the telegraph but do you want to see
more restrictions or do you agree with
andrew that how people are regulating
their own behavior already what's your
take on it
well i think that's exactly right people
are regulating their own behavior but
can i just say it's good that we do
agree about the need to get people
unvaccinated vaccine vaccinated and i
did quite a lot of
um obviously not actual jabbing but
volunteering especially through the
summer and i've seen doctors i've seen
nurses in the way that they speak to
people and i've known from gp practices
that they can really get into their
communities and there are very clever
subtle sensible ways that they have
proper conversations with people who
have otherwise taken this decision not
to get vaccinated and they can be
persuaded and of course one of the
biggest persuasions of all of that is
the fact that the majority of people in
hospital with covid on vacators on
ventilators in intensive care are people
who have not been vaccinated
and on the question of restrictions anna
no i'm i think we're about
about right but i think that we have to
see where the figures go and and i have
to say i can foresee that on boxing day
or thereafter there is a chance that the
government may have in england to
introduce some sort of measures
okay well that was the people are doing
it people are doing it
okay yeah and and there is more
information
that's right you know
don't you think that's right i mean
we're we're big enough and ugly enough
to make our own decisions now we've been
living with this wretched thing for best
part of what is it two years yeah we're
listening to chris whitty
yeah well but yeah but people just made
i just think people are sensible anna
and they know they don't need nanny
state government to keep telling us you
can do this and you can't do that i mean
it's ridiculous what's in some of these
countries scotland is saying that
football matches have to stop on boxing
day and yet they allowed a full
programme of football matches in the
scottish premier league tonight where's
the logic in that yeah but you always
find these illogicalities about when you
put in a restriction on a certain date
or when you stop people flying in or
flying out but but i think actually
people are working it out for themselves
and it is absolutely striking as i said
i don't live in london but i was in
lincoln today uh and it was really
noticeable that there's a lot less
people there and it's not just lincoln
it's throughout the whole of the
easterners and no doubt throughout the
whole of the country and that's because
people are not stupid but most
importantly they have listened to people
like chris witte and of course you know
we we've god knows we've been at this
now for nearly two years and the reason
try to say that people didn't do as the
government said
they they they obeyed the lockdown
because they understood why they needed
to and they agreed with it because if
they didn't agree with it they wouldn't
we wouldn't have abided by the rules in
the amazing way that millions and
millions of people did just a pity that
so many people
in number 10 downing street also didn't
follow the rules okay and let's let's
just move on i mean we may well hear
more in the next couple of days as far
as post um christmas uh restrictions for
england but we'll have to wait and see
let's have a quick look at what's inside
the ft there's a there's a column here
from from bronwyn
maddox um andrew what's this about
well she she's um she's from the
institute of government she in fact she
used to write for the ft many years ago
and she was a former colleague of mine
from the times and she's written a
really thoughtful piece about experts
and of course she's talking about uh
chris whitty of course he's become
almost well he's a household name now
isn't he about um how um boris johnson
at the beginning of this pandemic we
were following the advice of
science and then we're not always
following the advice of science and it's
all about really the position of
of advisors and she was pretty cross
with the tory mp um i've forgotten her
name anna might remember
really yeah morrissey who really flew uh
um chris whitty for speaking differently
to the prime minister at that down in
street briefing the other day she went
from in a tweet saying how dare an
unelected official uh effectively to
close the campaign
she went through it yeah yeah but but
the tweet was out there but i think she
spoke for quite a lot of people uh in
the tory party certainly you thought
actually it's the prime minister should
lead on this because he's the elected
official but at the elected prime
minister chris whittie's an unelected
official but he is the chief medical
officer chris curtis is getting a lot of
mentions um in this um
in this press preview i'm just going to
leave
this section with the mac cartoon always
worth visiting isn't it anna um on the
front of the telegraph um i can you know
i don't know if you can see it i'll i'll
i'll read it out there brilliant i'm
hoping christmas with my husband's
family will be like the omicron variant
not as bad as we all fear i mean thank
god for matt because he cheers us up um
because you could you don't have to buy
the paper in order to see that cartoon
because of course on on the internet and
obviously on programs like this we
always get these previews but he just
seems to nail it every time and it
brings a much needed smile to
everybody's faces because it's pretty
darned grim absolutely well on that
smiley note we will pause and take a
break but plenty more coming up in just
a moment including how might the next
chapter of the brexit saga play out if
the dup gets its way we're going to be
talking about that in a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight andrew pierce
and anna subray um and we're gonna move
from talking about kovid to talking
about brexit which we probably haven't
done for for a while um anna the front
page of the telegraph um has the
headline dup will urge trust to invoke
article 16. so what are they saying
um so this is uh
look liz trust foreign secretary has now
taken on the role um of being the brexit
negotiator because if you thought brexit
was done clearly hasn't been done
because there's this continuing round
about this the northern ireland protocol
now the northern ireland protocol
actually works very well for the vast
majority of people in northern ireland
but the dup
uh take great uh exception to it because
in effect what it's done is create a
border in the irish sea uh because of
the absolute desire not to have that
hard border between the republic of
ireland uh and between the north and the
uh and northern ireland and so the dup
facing elections in may has been
stirring up in my opinion quite a lot of
trouble in the unionist community
against this and i think what this is
really going to be is a test of whether
or not liz trust is going to side on if
you like the right
of the hard right of the conservative
party or whether she's and therefore
with the dup or whether she's going to
take a more pragmatic view
of the protocol um but if she does that
then it's argued that she'll probably
scupper her chances of becoming uh the
next leader of the conservative party
andrew is that how are you going to be
interesting
well i mean this is all about the dup
thinking they could lose the elections
to stormont next year uh the
uh the shin thing could actually become
the largest party so they want liz trust
to trigger article 16 because that will
show that they're standing up to the eu
it would be very it's known as the
nuclear option now i don't know what
she's going to do i think lord frosty
was doing that job wanted wanted to
trigger article 16 but was being
restrained i don't know who buy so it
will be a big test uh and there and and
uh anna sue is right in one respect a
lot of people on the brexit side of the
tory party will expect her to go in
there all guns blazing doing a
mississauga if you like swinging a
handbag uh it'll be a big test for us
she proves she's an able negotiator by
doing quite a lot of trade deals in her
previous role as international trade
secretary but this is going to be a big
one
okay one to watch then definitely and
we've only got about 20 seconds i think
i've only got time to show everyone the
photograph on the front of the guardian
maybe we can talk about it in the next
hour but it's basically people gathering
a stonehenge to mark the winter solstice
and it looked like a really beautiful
morning this morning anyway that will be
something that perhaps we'll come back
to but days are getting lighter yay